it's great to welcome today John tie to
the program a former NSA whistleblower
and a lawyer who back in 2017 founded
whistleblower aid which has provided
support to the anonymous Ukraine
whistleblower among many other things
John great to have you on today thank
you so much David so let's start with
your path executive order 12333 what is
it and how did that turn you into a
whistleblower thanks I was at the State
Department I worked in the Human Rights
Bureau from 2011 to 2014 on Internet
freedom and in that role I had a top
secret clearance so I was reading
intelligence from various countries
around the world and in June of 2013 the
Snowden disclosures became very public
news and I was part of the diplomatic
response to those disclosures both with
Germany Brazil other countries the
United Nations the Human Rights Council
in Geneva and during that period in the
in the nine months following that I got
a couple of briefings from the NSA on
the scope of u.s. signals intelligence
collection and what I learned was for
that whole year following the Snowden
leaks there hadn't been a single story
you despite front-page stories almost
every day hadn't been a single story on
the main legal authority that the NSA is
using to collect Americans data which is
as you said executive order 12 triple
three I was concerned about this I was
interested obviously care very deeply
about human rights and Americans privacy
and so basically this is a legal
loophole where the NSA is using an
authority originally intended to collect
foreigners data to actually sweep up
most of what we do online including US
persons American citizens this concerned
me
it wasn't being addressed in the in the
policy responses to the Snowden
disclosures and during that period I
became a whistleblower I did not want to
go to prison
I did not want to leave the country and
so I hired a couple of lawyers I paid
them thirteen thousand dollars this
would have been in 2014
probably March April 2014 and went
through the lawful disclosure process so
I met with the State Department
Inspector General the NSA Inspector
General House and Senate intelligence
committees and others and eventually
went through the pre-publication review
process and published an op-ed in The
Washington Post about this problem
so essentially you believe that order 12
triple three was being misused in order
to surveil Americans when as as it was
written you believe it was not meant to
apply to Americans yeah that's right it
was originally before the Internet there
were two legal regimes a statutory
regime for intelligence agency
operations inside the United States
which is under FISA the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act and then
twelve triple three was meant to cover
all the operations outside of our
borders with the internet that
distinction between inside our borders
and outside our borders became almost
irrelevant and a whole bunch of
Americans data is stored in data centers
around the world and it's treated as
foreign persons the data and collected
as such by the NSA when we think about
the government's treatment of prominent
and again even the use of the term
whistleblower versus leaker it's the
subject of debate and controversy so I'm
not trying to sort of like Prime the
discussion in any particular way but
when we think about the treatment of
folks like Edward Snowden Chelsea
Manning etc you have a very wide range
of opinion as to how these individuals
should be treated on one side you have
the idea that strictly speaking if
information was released in violation of
of how that information is classified or
if the information was obtained in a way
that violates the law or whatever that
that's essentially all that matters that
the content really does in an individual
should be punished as such on the other
side you have those who believe that
these are merely heroic acts that should
be celebrated and acted upon to change
what is the misbehavior of the
government including as you say you know
the misuse of an executive order
executive order in the case that you
discuss what is your general approaches
to how individuals should be treated by
the government and by the justice system
well our motto at whistleblower aid is
report government and corporate law
breaking without breaking the law so we
are a legal organization we would not
never help anyone to leak classified
information with that said these are
very difficult questions there aren't
easy answers and I think reasonable
people can disagree on some of this
stuff you know I we created this
organization so that people wouldn't
have to choose between you know
following their conscience and you know
avoiding harm to themselves so so we try
to help people follow the available
lawful disclosure process there are
often more options available than many
people realize and you know open up more
options so that people can keep their
careers don't have to go to prison and
still try to try to inform the public
about about what's going wrong you know
with those cases you mentioned those you
know those people didn't feel like they
had other options and you know we are
here to try to to help people not have
to put their career or their freedom in
jeopardy not not to be can overly
conspiratorial or dystopian or whatever
but what one can imagine situations
where one would believe that the
information they are trying to disclose
or what they are trying to blow the
whistle on is so damaging to the
government that going through the
process you describe might put them in
jeopardy might put them in danger might
allow them maybe to be silenced so is it
at least theoretically conceivable that
people could be in a position where they
want to go the route that you help
people go
but they believe that starting that
process actually puts them at risk or
may prevent the information from going
public yeah absolutely it's a risk
there's no easy things here and the more
the more important the disclosure the
more significant it is the more risky it
is for the individual and there's no way
around that
we're doing everything we can to
minimize those risks but the very first
thing I tell people when they come to me
is look the safest thing you can do is
go home and never talk to anyone about
this again so you know most people by
the time they get to me they've they've
crossed that bridge and they're there
they want to explore their options for
going forward but you know it's it's
risky and I would never say otherwise
can you talk a little bit for folks in
our audience who might be thinking about
WikiLeaks and the way that WikiLeaks has
been an intermediary with much
information that have been released can
you talk about how what you do is
completely different than what WikiLeaks
does absolutely we are not WikiLeaks we
do not help people leak classified
information we would never you know help
someone Julian Assange has been accused
of attempting to help someone to to hack
a government database we would never
help anyone try to do that you know look
that organisation has been credibly
accused of you know working wittingly or
unwittingly with Russian intelligence we
would never do anything like that I
swore an oath to the US Constitution
when I was at the State Department I'm
still down by that oath and take that
very seriously
so so we are very different from that
approach you know with that said I'll
say I don't agree with all of the
charges against the sons in the sense
that you know if the allegations are
true and I don't know the facts it
certainly would be illegal to try to
help someone hack a government database
I think publishing things received from
someone else shouldn't is not illegal
and should not be illegal so it's a
complicated legal matter when it comes
to the Ukraine
whistle blower can you talk a little bit
about do you believe that I mean this is
an individual who became the the target
of so many prominent people in the
public eye in the lead-up to Donald
Trump's eventual impeachment etc from
your perspective what what did they go
through this process in the correct way
absolutely so they immediately sought
legal counsel my colleague Andrew Bach I
and Mark Zaid were the lawyers for that
who are part of our team here at
whistleblower aid from the very
beginning they were planning how to do
this in a lawful way that would not
expose the client to criminal
prosecution or even dismissal from their
job inside a US intelligence agency that
person is still employed they did follow
all the rules they are entitled to legal
protections I think they're an example
of how the system of how people do
sometimes have more options than they
then they know about the legal process
here are very obscure some of these
statutes haven't been tested very often
and so we saw that with the attempts to
get this disclosure to Congress it was
bumpy the White House did try to block
Congress from receiving this in
violation of the laws but ultimately the
lawyers Android mark were able to get it
to Congress so I certainly wouldn't say
that our system is flawless but there
are often more options than people
understand and in this case the the
client did an amazing job in his true
hero were you able to or let me phrase
in a different way before the attempts
to out and create backlash against the
whistleblower started had you already
anticipated that it would reach the
degree that it did and how did you
advise the client to be prepared for
that in terms of security in terms of
practical things well first of all I
never had any direct contact with the
client Andrew and Mark Mike
colleagues were the ones representing
the client yeah you as they weren't
dressing yes yeah our firm so so I can't
confirm or deny any kind of you know
things about that person's identity or
anything like that broadly speaking as
soon as it was clear that this
implicated the president in the 2020
election yes it was obvious that this
was going to be a very high-profile
matter that they're going to be security
concerns from day one we brought in
top-level security people on the digital
side on the physical side as you may
know Mark Zaid one of the lawyers he was
getting death threats
we had armed guards on Mark Zaid 24
hours a day for months we and now the
Department of Justice is bringing a
criminal prosecution against one of the
individuals who was threatening to hurt
mark so it was a very serious situation
we knew that from the beginning and from
the beginning we were taking steps
that's really all I can say is it is
this once you understand the scope of
what is going on and again without
revealing anything particular in general
terms do you do extra I mean I know that
you say you always say to a lot of the
folks that come to you the easiest thing
for you is to go back home and never
speak about this again but are there
more conversations than normal of that
type given these particular
circumstances
III was not I I never had a conversation
with this client so I'm not gonna speak
to that fair enough
when we look going forward is there
anything that you believe took place in
or surrounding the Ukraine whistleblower
situation that may sort of change the
way these things are potentially handled
in the future both by a firm like yours
representing someone like this but also
the way that Congress the House of
Representatives and others worked in
receiving the information yeah clearly
threats intimidation starting
with the President of the United States
the president's family senior officials
US senators attempts to identify
intimidate this person are extremely
harmful arguably illegal in some cases
you you know you could make the argument
that any kind of presidential effort to
intimidate a whistleblower itself
constitutes you know an offense and so
there were serious problems here some of
those people should be held accountable
for their actions
it is never right to try to identify a
whistleblower with with the knowledge
that's you know some extremists would
would would threaten that person
possibly act violently against that
person um there need to be stronger
protections in place arguably that kind
of behavior should be criminalized which
it's not today except in certain narrow
circumstances and you know Congress
needs to identify the gaps that were
apparent in the system and and filled
them with legislation and certainly
there needs to be reforms Andrew and
Mark published New York Times op-ed two
or three weeks ago that laid out some of
their ideas for that so clearly there's
room for improvement yes certainly an
understatement I would say room for
improvement for for sure as in regards
to a lot of the elements of how this all
went down
John tie former NSA whistleblower and
attorney who in 2017 founded
whistleblower aide John so great to
speak to you and I really appreciate
your time today thanks David